[Music]
the marvel cinematic universe has
clearly experienced
massive success however that doesn't
mean the studio's
sprawling saga is devoid of missteps
from unfortunate casting decisions
to creative control issues here are some
of the regrets that the people behind
the franchise
have had about the universe they helped
create
thor the dark world has not enjoyed the
best reputation among
mcu movies not only did it get the worst
reviews of any feature in the franchise
but even its own director alan taylor
has publicly expressed disappointment
over how the project turned out
specifically taylor has been pretty open
about how he didn't end up having as
much of a creative impact on the
production
as he wanted the first inkling of taylor
having a difficult experience on the
project came up as early as
october 2013 when the director while
promoting the theatrical release of the
dark world
revealed that he and marvel studios had
disagreements over how to deliver
exposition throughout the movie
taylor would get more explicit in later
interviews coming right out and saying
that the final cut of the movie was
different from what he initially wanted
taylor explained to uproxx the marvel
experience
was particularly wrenching because i was
sort of given absolute
freedom while we were shooting and then
in post it turned into a different movie
so that is something i hope never to
repeat and don't wish upon
anybody else based on that quote it
sounds like taylor definitely won't be
directing any marvel movies in the near
future
unless of course he has a serious heart
to heart with executives at the studio
i wish i could trust you it took a few
mcu appearances for the franchise to
really get the god of thunder right
thor ragnarok solidified what this
character was all about but before then
thor was on shakier ground the character
was a little more traditional in his
initial outings
and he lacked the consistently engaging
and subversive personalities that his
fellow avengers received
one of several ways thor's earlier
appearances came up short was in a tiny
detail from the first thor movie
one related to chris hemsworth's
eyebrows yes
his eyebrows this revelation came
directly from the president of marvel
studios
mr kevin feige himself he said that if
he could go back in time
and change one thing about the film it
would be that they would not have died
hemsworth's eyebrows blonde
while most viewers weren't bothered by
or even noticed
thor's light eyebrows others had a more
extreme reaction
feige further explained his feelings
about the dye job to uprocks
hemsworth was great and awesome and
pulled it off but there are a couple of
shots i watch
and i'm like oh my god that poor guy we
made him freaking dye his eyebrows
that's ridiculous
and i can laugh about it now because
hemsworth is thor
and he doesn't need long hair or a cape
or a hammer
or two eyeballs to beat thor when you're
making a movie
you have to make some tough decisions
nobody knows this
better than writer director james gunn
who's never been shy when it comes to
talking about personal favorite scenes
and lines
that didn't make the final cut of his
various directorial efforts
in terms of his first motion picture for
the marvel cinematic universe
he openly talked about how one of his
favorite lines and guardians of the
galaxy
was omitted from the film's final cut
the line in question is a follow-up to a
discussion that was used in the movie
in which peter quilt notes that he comes
from a planet of outlaws
drax responds that this sounds like a
place he'd like to explore
which inspires peter to casually say
that drax should come and visit sometime
in the final cut this is the end of
their exchange
however originally drax also noted that
while he was on earth he would like to
quote
kill many people there the brutal joke
ended up on the cutting room floor
but gunn loves the line so much that he
said the following on twitter i so
wanted george lucas it back in
i can't tell you that makes it pretty
apparent that this is one line
gunn regrets leaving behind from the
theatrical version of guardians of the
galaxy
while gunn might feel some
disappointment about this one missed
moment
drax still delivered some of our
favorite lines of the movie
you're an imbecile filmmaker louis
letterier
has had a career resurgence in recent
years thanks to his work directing
episodes of netflix tv shows like the
dark crystal age of resistance
and lupine however long before those
programs
leteriae helmed big budget blockbusters
like the second marvel cinematic
universe movie ever
the incredible hulk that feature ended
up becoming an odd duck
in the mcu pantheon thanks to a variety
of factors
including how the film's lead actor
edward norton never reprised the role
again
as well as its distribution rights
belonging to universal pictures
latier himself has contributed to the
weird reputation of the incredible hulk
by openly expressing his regrets about
shortcomings with the project
latier told huffpost back in 2013 i've
started movies without screenplays both
on clash of the titans and on hulk
and that is tremendously stressful
because you have a tendency to
overcompensate with effects
you haven't tested it in your head you
didn't run it over and over again and
figure it out he also noted that some
parts of the incredible hulk
are more identifiably his than others
laterier explained
the first half of the movie is really
mine and the second half is the studio's
expected hulk movie
two giants kicking each other's ass the
incredible hulk didn't quite
match people's expectations either
critically or financially
and it apparently didn't reach latier's
own ambitions either
phil coulson became such a beloved
character during his time in the marvel
cinematic universe that many fans
upon seeing him perish at loki's hand in
the avengers
wanted nothing more than for him to
return well they got their wish
and then some since coulson was brought
back for the abc
tv series agents of shield co-created by
avengers director
joss whedon the decision to resurrect
this character inspired as many fans as
it did to tractors with skeptics opining
that going down this route was a cheap
storytelling ploy
surprisingly whedon himself actually
fell
into the ladder camp in the spring of
2015
whedon told mental floss that bringing
back coulson removed quote
some of the punch out of his death scene
for me he then went on to say that the
whole
ordeal of reviving coulson reflected
some of his own
issues with blockbuster storytelling
during his mental floss
interview whedon elaborated on the topic
it's difficult because you're living in
a franchise world
you can't kill anyone or anybody
significant i think it's disingenuous to
say we're going to fight this great
battle but there's not going to be any
loss
so my feeling in these situations with
marvel is that if somebody has to be
placed on the altar and sacrificed
i'll let you guys decide if they stay
there while coulson returning may have
been a dream come true for some fans
for whedon it was a much more
complicated experience that brought in
moments of reflection
and regret still plenty of fans had
another reaction to coulson's
resurrection
in his second appearance in the marvel
cinematic universe
andy circus made a memorable splash as
ulysses claw
and in a rare live-action turn from the
actor in a blockbuster movie
circus proved he didn't need motion
capture to bring the goods to the big
screen
throughout a film that covered some very
heavy material
claw provided moments of welcome levity
during his reprisal of the hattaway song
what is love
and in his joy about sending a bevy of
cash flying in every direction during a
casino fight
claw proved such an enjoyable presence
in the film
in fact that even black panther writer
director ryan coogler
regrets killing off the character in the
middle of the movie a few months after
black panther hit theaters
coogler told the toronto sun i like claw
i was bugged by having to do that
it's tough when you have to kill
characters off and i really did love
that character
i love andy he's a lovely person but
again it's one of those things where
when you've got so many people in a
movie
some of them have to go it's
understandable that coogler would want
to keep claw around
given how positively the villain was
received however
at the very least couglar can take
solace in knowing that he wrote a
character who's so memorable
that people miss him when he's gone when
it came time for marvel to make a live
action feature film adaptation of doctor
strange there were several thorny
elements of the classic version of the
superhero that needed to be ironed out
chiefly the dr strange story originally
had a problematic approach to eastern
culture
that included the initial incarnation of
wong as
merely being a manservant another issue
concerned the character
of the ancient one a mentor who if
executed wrong
could have been seen as a wisened asian
master stereotype
marvel's decision on how to approach the
character of the ancient one
was to cast decidedly caucasian
performer tilda swinton
as the tibetan marvel comics character
according to dr
strange director scott derrickson the
reason they went with a white woman
instead of an asian actress was to avoid
the dragon lady stereotype
however the casting decision inspired a
wave of controversy and
accusations of whitewashing making
things even more complicated
dr strange screenwriter c robert cargill
also revealed that another reason for
the casting was to not offend
the chinese government which has a very
charged history with tibet
naturally this only inspired further
uproar
swinton's casting has become so infamous
that even mcu boss kevin feige has gone
on record to say
we thought we were being so smart and so
cutting edge
we are not going to do the cliche of the
wise and
old wise asian man but it was a wake-up
call to say
well wait a minute is there any other
way to figure it out is there any other
way to both
not fall into the cliche and cast an
asian actor
the answer to that of course is yes
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the marvel cinematic universe
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one